i've decided to do a a series of
short vignettes about the future
headlines of the future they're called
black af
scenarios in the news and if you get the
term black af you know what i'm talking
about
so 2020 the nonprofit california black
speculative arts movement launches in
july to promote black's bucket of art
and design with its partners
the museum of children's art game heads
and ancestral futures
in 2020 the election is in dispute the
military intervenes with supreme court
approval
as biden assumes the presidency the u.s
goes into restorative justice healing
and national reconciliation to honor
black lives
to apologize for slavery it becomes a
catalyst for reparations
as the first stage of the cares act
creating a responsible and equitable
society
fast forward to 2022 california b sam
participates in the first california
equitable futures network
of imagination action conference where
hundreds of
black people of color and lgbtqia
organizations showcase
their community vision futures for 2032.
again we're in 2025 now community
futures school now has a
1 000 alumni with professional
certificates in strategic forecasting
for the communities and are in demand as
foresight
coalition builders wow
2300 now nova africa
l5 space world nation wakanda 5
celebrates its 200th anniversary
with earth and mars black diasporas in
vibranium mine
linkedin to share and leap up
in the anti-gravity ida b wells dance
liberatory design at its finest
i end there saying and want to imagine
afrofutures with you where black futures
matters